you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between lev pol guy of ski and rashidun
as met nob from the 1958 tournament held
in Sochi Russia this is one of the
greatest attacking games ever many
having it as Desmond nobs immortal
Rasheed without question rivaled the
great mikhail tall in the areas of
imaginative creative attacking style
chess so let's dive right in and see
what exactly made this particular game
so special we had whole guy ops key
opening with d4 Nez met not replying
Knight f6 c4 d69 c3 e 5 with this we
have an old Indian defense Ukranian
variation giving white an opportunity to
exchange Queens if he so chooses in the
game however we saw efore I would like
to go down this particular line briefly
because as I was reviewing for this
video I noticed a very sharp
continuation one that can catch a white
player who tries to land Forks on these
f7 and see seven squares with the king
knight and queen knight Knight f3 can be
met with simply knight c6 e developing
move there to defend a 5 there may
sometimes be a reason to not want to
play your Knight to c6 but rather a 6
where from a 6 he would defend the c7
square but Knight to c6 is a perfectly
good forward developing move Knight g5
is met with King EA and Knight b5 well
this is what I found quite interesting
there's Bishop b4 check you excute
exchange bishops and follow up with King
e7 you ignore the threat on c7 if he's
taken wieck and find themselves in some
serious hot water fast
the white king is under fire king c3 you
ignore the threat on the rook and
instead try and kick the night away from
the e4 square Knight takes rook pick up
the night and if the knight tries to run
away well he
here comes 94 here comes Knight d4 the
white King gets rocked back a punch is
thrown at the king rook and if he's
saved while the Queen rook is now lost
with this cute move Knight b3 if pawn
takes Knight rook d1 the rook is won and
the white pieces are completely
paralyzed one other detail is that
instead of Knight to c7 at this moment
here suppose f3 notice on f3 the knight
can't make use of e4 but he can
certainly make use of EA and why is this
relevant
well the knight will not be saved d3
Bishop here will soon enter a position
where black has the two minor pieces
versus the rook and black is the
preferred side I just wanted to
highlight those details I found that
quite interesting okay well in the game
it was instead e4 black takes and gains
now a tempo develops with tempo on the
Queen Queen d2 so white has a better
pawn presence in the center efore in c4
versus d6 but that comes at the cost of
some time black again was able to
develop with tempo with this Queen d2
move there is also a tell in the
position if you're going to be
obstructing the Bishop on this diagonal
well you could pretty much anticipate
that white will not eventually feeing
Ketel the Bishop b2 but immediately
feeing Ketel the bishop I use the word
immediately for very particular reason
after the move g6 if black if excuse me
white does not go in for b3 and Bishop
b2 right away
suppose Knight f3 Bishop g7 and only now
this well that's tactically vulnerable
because of Knight takes on e4 exploiting
this unprotected rook on a1 so with
Queen to d2 in other words white is not
only saying I will fee and keto my
bishop but I will do so immediately
because of that little trick on e4 needs
to come very quickly
so that's what we have g6 b3 both
bishops are feeling kettled in time this
tactic is now not available black is
quick to castle still having a lead in
development white has still nothing over
here on the Kings side and there is also
the potential pressure on e4 which is
prompting this particular placement of
the bishop sensing more pressure on this
square the bishop is there to defend and
now Knight g4 okay well entering the
white position with this clearing the
way for the Queen looking to also pivot
on the e5 square this is a typical
maneuver that you can see not only the
g4 square but also d7 both have these
options of getting to the e5 square
maybe even Knight d7 c5 and some lines
but some Knight pivot some King Knight
pivot I should say clearing the way for
the bishop and having new possibilities
available so Knight g4 also putting
pressure on h2 + f2 Knight on G to e2
and this is allowing Queen h4 this is
often regarded as one of the best
squares here for the King Knight f3 and
one of the reasons for that is because
of the squares it watches over on the
White King side the h2 square h4 and g5
well with the knight not around on f3
you might as well start thinking about
potential Queen moves Queen h4 is played
right away and reply to Knight on GTE to
pinpointing f2 and h2 and it becomes a
bit awkward for white to have to defend
these threats the move played in the
game was Knight g3 but one of the better
defenses is g3 not really a movie want
to play weakening these light squares
the bishop
one of the Knights at some point
potentially being able to make use of
those squares this is one of the better
moves but instead we saw Knight g3 if
you're wondering it all about the move
Knight f3 you know why wasn't this
particular move played I don't know that
I have a great reason for
but one thing that I was looking into is
that black has the move Knight e5 and
what is this doing well this is
welcoming some exchanges keep in mind it
is black who has a slight space
disadvantage I don't know how relevant
exactly that is in this position where
maybe what is more important is
development in time but nevertheless and
Knight playing to f3 can be challenged
immediately with Knight e5 forking both
of these white minor pieces and an
exchange will occur if the bishop is to
move away there can be a capture like
this and the night is now planted on d4
that seems to be like a good sequence of
moves there and if something other than
that something other than Bishop to e2
if black is capturing I should say if
white is capturing black is recapturing
on e5 and this Knight will be landing on
d4 soon enough having great control over
that hole in the white position notice
the corresponding d5 square is not a
hole on the black side because there's
always still the c6 move to defend okay
well at the end of the day what did we
have it was the King Knight playing to
e2 not f3 Queen h4 Knight g3 and now
Knight to e5 a better move at this point
instead of Knight to e5 would be to
actually chip away at these dark squares
add additional fuel to f7 there is this
interesting shot Bishop to d4
hammering away at f2 and maybe one of
the only defenses is to throw your
knight into reverse not a move you want
to have to play but you need to do
something about the f2 pawn moving him
is just weakening this e3 square and
this is big trouble with Bishop e3 94
IDs of a check maybe grabbing here
grabbing the knight you don't want to
touch this pawn on this dark square you
move him you weaken your dark squares so
Knight d1 would probably be the best at
this point and now black and simply move
forward and blast open the position with
that 5 e takes there's Bishop takes and
again the position is opening up all the
black pieces are
working here we basically have black I
guess the quick summary playing on 5/8
of the board well we didn't have that we
didn't have [ __ ] of d4 instead it was
95 white castles and now f5 looking to
open up the position looking to move
even further with f5 gaining a tempo
against this awkward placement for the
Knights always very awkward squares the
ones I have highlighted for the Knights
they get kicked around sometimes by rook
pawns in this case we're seeing an
instance of this f4 move with maybe even
an ensuing f3 which would make that
central pawn the heart of this King side
structure flinch and weaken the light
squares so it's already a very critical
point for team white maybe the best move
is to capture at this point but instead
we saw f3 not allowing f4 and then f3
but this again is weakening these two
dark squares something that black takes
advantage of right away we have Bishop
h6 gaining a tempo on the Queen she's
very limited in this position having to
watch over the bishop the knight has
pressure on it and well she can't go too
far right if she goes to one of these
two squares you're simply inviting a new
piece into the white position with tempo
so Queen goes back and now we have F for
this position is after f4 was played
this is a position that's closely
related to the Kings Indian defense Mar
del Plata variation one where if you
could imagine pawns on these 5 and d5
squares a black pawn on e5 and a white
pawn on d5 this is the direction black
would be wanting to go in to get in a g4
break and white trying to play on the
Queen side it's not exactly the same
case here of course but still the
similar idea regarding pawn breaks black
would really like to get in g4 and is
very fast to do
just that this is even more effective
having this night on the e5 square
because it adds pressure to these Queen
side squares f3 and also g4 great
he's facilitating this GeForce advanced
very nicely black is in a very strong
position and some of the reasons he is
in a strong position in a more
aggressive position is due to the better
queen position White Queen is home the
black queen is of course planted very
securely
she can't be kicked away so easily from
this h4 Square and we have this f4 move
and now g5 moves soon to be g4 where the
white position is being controlled by
the black pawns soon enough we're going
to have this pawn on g4 and 25% of
White's
kingside position is controlled by just
two black pawns this is a big problem
for team whites this goal is to actually
get all the way down to g3 as we will
soon see there's a very interesting
tactical motif available with these
pawns gaining so much depth in the
position one thing I had question at
this moment here instead of f4 something
that seemed to be crying out to me and
is not necessarily bad at all is Bishop
to e3 check and only after King h1 to
then follow up with f4 I believe this
was another direction black could have
gone in and I think maybe one of the
reasons this is maybe not chosen is
because eventually white can one day
gain a tempo back in some sense after
Knight to d5 something you would really
want to do on the white side not only
because it opens the diagonal for the
bishop but it also improves the Knights
position and throws a punch at the
bishop maybe this is something black
wanted to avoid altogether this tempo
type of move against the bishop on e3
well in the game instead of inserting
this check first it was the immediate
kicking of the night with f4 92
g5 Knight d5 c7 is hit but the white
King is under some serious fire here
comes g4 if you think you could take
this pawn you're wrong
Knight takes pawn is going to get
crushed so much so that the move g3 is
well you can't see in the screen right
now but you can't see it in the video
but the top move here for white after g3
is sadly rook to f2 that's how bad this
position is for Team white making the
move h3 well that's not going to survive
because this is the tactical motif I'm
referring to Bishop takes h3 again
something we would see in the Kings
Indian defense Mar del Plata variation
and black is absolutely killing team
white rook f2 is maybe the best defense
Queen h2 is a main threat you get the
idea
white is completely busted there goes a
bishop as well so my main point here is
that if you think he could get away with
taking the pawn on c7 you're way off
this is a very serious threat very
important tactical motif to be aware of
g3 h3 and then to sacrifice on h3 and
because of the seriousness of this
threat white needs to take action white
needs to stop the pond from advancing to
g3
by playing g3 himself the move Queen d3
well keep in mind the Queen has a job to
watch over the bishop sell Queen to e1
trying to stop this advance is just not
good so g3 was played in the game we
have the light squares now being
weakened because of that last move F
takes G H takes G and now the black
Queen goes even deeper into the white
position Queen H 3 F 4 tries to keep the
position closed the knight is attacked
and what do you do this is I believe
this 19th move is one of the first star
moves of the game the follow up is
Bishop to e6 developing a piece who
would have thought all right just
getting that last piece involved
and knowing that this night is in fact
immune from capture because of this
little trick if the night is taken we
take the night here which is doing what
removing the defender of III and this is
going to be lethal capture here it's in
fact a mate and one and then two so the
night is indirectly defended in other
words on e5 it's immune from capture due
to this little trick of capturing the
night and then slicing into the white
position on e3 so what is white do and
reply Bishop to c2 being a little bit
sneaky here now this capture could be
met with a recapture whip check so how
does black cope with that well it's rook
to f7 interfering with this idea so this
idea is still back on if pawn takes
Knight there's Bishop takes Knight if
the Queen takes there is no check which
would still allow this matin - threat so
that was a sneaky move this is also not
only preventing light from recapturing
on d5 with check but also preparing to
simply get the last piece involved into
the attack the Queen rook on the f8
square so following up we have white at
this point trying to simply run he is
just trying to make his way to safer
ground he's made some serious
concessions on the Kings side and is
just heading for the hills here are
running for the hills I should also
mention something else here instead of
this Bishop to e6 move this may seem
very appealing to throw the knight and
f3 and I believe would be one of the top
moves to consider since it comes with
check but even though this Knight is
very deep in the white position there
doesn't seem to be a good follow up the
King goes to f2 the Queen could give a
check the King can run to e3 and maybe
it's black who all of a sudden needs to
be a bit concerned because well maybe
one day this is in fact a threat and now
there's also a second one to maybe win
the bishop
the main point of the main tension point
in the position I guess we could say is
this square F 4 but it certainly has
well it certainly has its fair share of
defenders there's not going to be any
sacrifices in this position here with
both Knights controlling that square as
well as the pawn on g3 but this may
again be tempting to want to go in for
this check but it does not work out for
black so in the game it was again Bishop
to e6 the bishop backs up again with
this idea in mind of recapturing with
check black interferes with this idea
rook to f7 the King takes a hike the
Queen now enters the position with Czech
King to e3 and now Bishop takes Knight
pawn takes Bishop Knight b4 another
piece being thrown into the white
position and now the follow up move rook
to h1 so what exactly do we do with the
Queen in this position how do we reply
on the black side if you like to at this
point go ahead and pause the video see
what move you would play in this
position okay the move here and I
believe the star move of the game
without question is rook takes f4 doing
absolutely nothing about the threat on
the Queen and setting up a double check
with rook to f3 in the game we did in
fact have rook takes Queen rook f3 and
the King is now flying all the way to
the center and it is surrounded by the
black pieces clearly both Knight still
on the board the rook cutting the King
off the bishop close to returning to
contribute to controlling the dark
squares in the center of the board I
should mention also at this point here
if something other than rook takes Queen
suppose pawn takes rook
well there's Bishop takes pawn Knight
here and then at the end of this the
white queen will be lost Queen takes
Knight
takes Queen one other variation would
include instead of taking on f4 with the
pawn first suppose Knight takes well
then you get again there's this
immediate in this case Knight takes on
c2 and the white queen would be one so
you pretty much have to go for this
variation here after the rook h1 rook
takes f4 pretty much have to take the
queen on the white side that's what we
did have rook takes Queen rook f3 that's
double check double check that King must
always move King to d4 and now Bishop to
g7 setting up another discovered attack
against the king moving the night maybe
even a double check should he go to c6
the move played here was a 4 I should
mention instead of Bishop to g7 this is
not necessarily the most accurate Bishop
g7 a better move would have been c5 with
the idea that after white captures on c6
the move or I should say the square c6
is no longer controlled by the white
side which allows black to now play b5
and then threaten a checkmate with night
on e captures c6 and that would be mate
so this was the idea
I believe this right here is the idea
that white saw at this point right here
after Bishop g7 I believe white saw this
idea now with c5 and then b5 which
prompted the reply a4 after this advance
the game is going to be over this is in
fact a checkmate in eighth and white is
completely dead before I show the final
combination of moves the sequence of
eight moves or I should say seven moves
and then resignation I'd like to
highlight a very interesting defensive
resource that white have in this
position certainly one that is very
difficult to
up with one of the reasons for that is
because it's a retreating move namely
Knight g1 trying to kick the rook off of
this third rank so the King could
finally have some new squares to run to
you really don't want to run deeper into
the black King position you'd like to
bail out and go in this direction or
something but what we can still do on
the black side after Knight to g1 is
play C 5 D take C Knight e to d3 check
be 5 bishop takes e5 and the King needs
to go in this direction playing here
runs into a million-one with d5 so this
line that I'm showing right here is
still very very interesting
I believe this game would still be very
very famous if we went in this direction
where white came up with this Knight to
g1 move because of how this could end
King a5 Bishop c7 King a4 Knight takes
b2 King takes Knight a5 King a3 and at
the end of this which may be one of the
best things we could have the best
results in this current position is
potentially this perpetual check the
game entering has a draw but what a draw
that would have been well we didn't have
the game ending in a draw
black ended up winning this one after a
4 here comes the final flurry of moves
c5 D takes seed and only move B takes e
threatening checkmate with c5 the only
way to prevent this is to interpose on
the d3 square with the bishop or the
Queen so that the king could try to run
to this square Bishop d3 was played
whether it's the Queen or the bishop
playing here black would reply in the
same way simply taking the bishop width
it's this discovered check came to c4 is
best only to prolong the inevitable
if pawn push this is only a faster main
do to Bishop takes e5
four or even c4 is met with d5 mate so
instead of e5 the game continued King c4
d5 check pawn takes pawn and only move
pawn takes pawn King b5 and only move
rook b8 King a5 and only move this King
has come quite a ways running all the
way to d4 shifting over to this a5
square nice King hike or a king walk
after King to a 5 we have knight c6 and
it is at this point that pull guy offski
resigned after King to a6 Black is in
the interesting position where he has a
couple different check mates in one
rookie 6 or even knight on D to b4 would
do the trick so a very interesting game
clearly not all the time that you get to
see this little King walk in the middle
of the board the King eventually getting
mated a queen sacrifice and one thing
that struck me is very interesting is
how well this is my question to you
those of you that are viewing this video
right now how deep in fact did you think
Nesbitt naav calculated in this game I
think to just voice my opinion on this
one I think after King 2 f2 was played I
believe it was at this point that he had
already calculated this sacrifice on f4
because at this point you're kind of
going all-in with Queen h4 because if
things aren't working out you're really
setting yourself up for a disaster
notice the follow-up here was what to
take the knight and then we have this
recapture there's a thread on your
knight you really have to be super
accurate to know after Knight b4 and
rook to a1 there is in fact this idea in
mind I found this
clearly a very interesting game to see
I'd be interested to know what your
thoughts are and how far how deep
Desmond knob calculated in this one I
believe it was at least 7 moves deep if
we count both white and black moves but
feel free to share what your
thoughts on this one I hope you enjoyed
this one with the little king walk and
the eventual checkmate of the white King
will not check me but resignation due to
a checkmate in one threat at this point
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you